some demonstrators in France blocked
roads While others set up picket lines
outside factories many schools were shut
and transport services were disrupted as
some public sector workers took part in
a nationwide strike we're stopping
lorries from entering but we've let the
night Walkers out everyone wants to
strike and everyone supports us
anger is growing among workers with the
French government's plan to reform the
pension system and raise the retirement
age by two years to 64. protesters in
Paris said it was an erosion of their
rights
it's an unfair reform another reform
that favors the rich it's undemocratic
because most people are against it
but the government doesn't want to hear
from them because it only listens to the
elite
we've seen in other countries that
raising the legal age to left
it's not good for the country not for
the economy not for the health reforming
the pension system was one of French
president Emmanuel macron's campaign
promises he says it needs to be
modernized because it's too complex and
costs too much money
foreign
in the French Parliament opposition to
the reform has been at times as Fierce
as in the streets but the government
says it won't back down
you've chosen outrage you make sweeping
statements you chose blockades and
obstruction we chose debate and
discussion
across party doesn't have a
parliamentary majority so passing the
reform won't be easy and pressure to
scrap it is mounting Trade union leaders
have called for more strikes and
protests in the coming days Natasha
Butler Al Jazeera Paris